this Theory breaks my brain a little bit
the asteroid that is supposed to wipe
out the dinosaurs misses the sea
monsters are
so appealing as for whether or not the
first car to wake up had an existential
crisis very possible well I think my
brain is still broken welcome back to
new rock stars my name is Anna vanston
and if you've ever even dipped your baby
toe into the Pixar side of YouTube
you'll have heard of the Pixar theory
the theory that every single Pixar movie
exists within the same universe on the
same timeline there have been several
different proposals for how the Pixar
movies might all fit together on the
same timeline including one of the most
popular ones made by the super Carlin
brothers and that's the theory we'll be
focusing on today because I think I can
poke some holes in it and who better to
join me in disproving the super Carlin
Brothers Pixar Theory than one of the
super Carlin Brothers we have Jay with
us today Jay welcome to the channel hi
and I thank you so much for having me
this we've been stringing together the
Pixar theory for like the last 11 years
or so so every time a new movie comes
out we make like a new video and try and
decide how that one fits in there people
can get very serious about the Pixar
theory and it's like guys it's all just
a bunch of movies so how it fits
together is really just a fun thing to
think about for me it's more of like a
game at this point it's a thing for the
community to do together to figure out
how every single movie is connected the
Easter eggs are there like you can see
Riley and Finding Dory so it's like
inside out and Finding Dory must take
place in the same universe and then it's
like there's Buzz Lighty you're Finding
Nemo so so Toy Story has to take place
in the same universe so so some amount
of consistency has to exist it's just
figuring out what is the big story and
speaking of for our audience be sure to
go check out the complete Pixar Theory
2022 is your most recent one correct
yeah and while you're also on there they
also cover nerdy fictional stuff
including Marvel Star Wars so much more
so you know stay while kick your feet up
now okay there are three main things
that I want to talk about today just cuz
I keep getting caught up on them and
those points are cars taking place
during Wall-E Luca's ties to the
Monsters Ink world and the witch from
Brave being boo can we talk yeah
absolutely we can talk about that I'm
not surprised you're bringing up cars
cars is definitely the biggest pill to
small I will admit it um but that's okay
that's okay it still fits cars is the
one I keep hoping like the next movie is
g to help me explain cars more this will
be the one this will be the one that
explains in the meime this is the
explation we have so first off your
timeline states that Wall-E takes place
a 100 years after when several of the
other Pixar movies like Ratatouille and
Finding Nemo took place and already I
think of some of the scenes in Wall-E
where we see the timeline of the
previous captains and like the tape of
Hello Dolly which seem to indicate that
the humans used to look like we do in
the real world before slowly morphing
into the lobular beings that they appear
as in the movie however obviously this
realistic appearance of the humans
wasn't in Ratatouille or any of the
other movies that would be 100 years
prior on the timeline how could the
Captain who was Captain in 2105 or even
Hello Dolly which have real looking
humans how would that have overlapped
with the other movies timelines great
question also fantastic use of the word
blob you just say um than you thank you
it's my word of the day so I know this
is one of the things that when I'm
watching wallet it's always like
surprising to me that they decided to
use like liveaction people the way I
interpret this is it's more of like an
artistic style they were going for like
in the same way that like turning red
has a different art style than Toy Story
or Luca has a different art style than
Ratatouille like what they're doing
especially in the more recent movies is
adapting the art style to match the
theme of the movie but that doesn't mean
everything doesn't still take place in
the same universe even though like the
the art changes so while it's weird to
think of like the liveaction people as
being a different art style that is how
I interpret it for the sake of Wall-E
okay okay you're saying that even in
Finding Nemo there might be a copy of
Hello Dolly lying around somewhere but I
mean they look like uh uh the
Ratatouille people maybe in that one yes
AB possibly possibly exactly so yeah
like if if Andy was watching Hello Dolly
maybe to him it just looks like the
regular Pixar animated people and just
to be clear according to the Pixar
theory is this planet supposed to be our
Earth but in an alternate timeline yes
so the the way the Pixar theory kicks
off is in the good dinosaur where at the
very beginning of the movie you see that
the asteroid that is supposed to wipe
out the dinosaurs misses and so that is
sort of like the Catalyst for the rest
of the changes that we see going forward
okay so then I'm not done with cars we
we're coming back to cars so then the
theory the theory also states that cars
happened 700 years after the humans
leave Earth on the Axiom and that the
cars have come to life using human
energy reanimating in the order they
were cared for and taking on their
previous owners personalities a broad
summary but is is there anything
important that I missed there well so
it's not that cars is taking place 700
years after the humans leave it's taking
place during the 700 years that they're
gone on the that they're gone yeah okay
okay okay okay well even even still this
Theory breaks my brain a little bit I
mean okay one of the cars had to wake up
first right but in the video you admit
that they still need gas and other car
stuff to run I'm a gear Head you might
be able to tell I'm super totally so if
this is during the 700 years that the
humans are gone I mean how did the first
car to wake up function like diesel
starts to grade after about a year right
and also and also did this car have an
existential crisis seeing all of the
other cars laying around in animate like
if they have their owner memories and
thoughts that's like waking up and
seeing everyone dead on the ground to be
morbid sorry yeah those are two very
good points so as far as like the the
fuel and stuff like we have to remember
that they're apparently waking up in a
world where like the axioms existed so
it's a world where technology has
advanced a little bit further than we
have here in the real world at the end
of Wall-E when the Axiom returns from
like deep space to earth like however
far away it is it gets back within like
seconds so the kind of fuel available to
the planet Earth when they left is
better than what we know it to be now so
that's my explanation for how the fuel
hasn't like degraded or something like
that as for whether or not the first car
to wake up had an existential crisis
very possible very possible they woke up
and were like what is going on I don't
know what happened there cuz they don't
show us what happened when the first car
woke up all we know is that eventually
they overcame whatever existential
crisis they might have been having and
managed to start forming a functioning
Society all right they they talk to
their car therapist for a when they woke
up I mean shoot you got to wait a while
and so and did the cars rebuild things
that were already there like for
instance the statue that uh commemorates
Mr Stanley founding Radiator Springs in
1909 might have been there already but
it wouldn't have been the car version of
Mr Stanley that we see in the movie you
know that's a really uh interesting
thought because I think while the cars
are there they build new stuff as well
but I think they also are experiencing
the entire world like through a cified
lens so like in cars to you can see
Gusto from Ratatouille it's the same as
Gusto but they just see it through that
like car lens so as far as like the
statue of Stanley in Radiator Springs
like it's very possible that like andley
the the car woke up and founded Radiator
Springs and they constructed a statue of
him and that's just what's there but
it's also possible that you're right the
cars are just it's actually a statue of
a human and then cars are just seeing it
as a car that's like a it's hard to
exactly know because we just don't know
we don't get to like look back at when
Stanley was alive but either of those is
totally possible okay okay so what about
the car bugs and the car cows they're
alive but I assume there weren't bugs
and cows driving cars in the real world
and also on top of that in the beginning
of cars you can see non-car birds on the
telephone wire it's only a couple frames
but but they're there shouldn't all the
animals on Earth be extinct at this
point of the timeline what's going on
here well they should be I think the car
cows in particular are actually tractors
which I think are just taking on the
personality of cows the very brief birds
that we do see that are like not cified
Birds which there are there are cified
birds within cars they just look like
tiny little planes like on the runways
and stuff like that that's a nod to like
the Pixar short like for the birds which
as I said we don't totally count like
doesn't out there from being the birds
there but even that is still like kind
of okay because we know that not every
kind of real life Wildlife has died off
when Cruz is driving on the beach in
Cars 3 at one point she has to stop
because she doesn't want to hit like a
little Krabby there there are still
crabs around on Earth even though um it
seems like there's no non-car things
even if you go to Finding Dory like
there's a scene where they're swimming
through like all of this like pollution
and stuff the one thing that's still
existing in all the pollution bes
besides the giant likee bioluminescent
squid is crabs they're like everywhere
so it's like crabs are able to adapt to
the pollution which fits in with cruise
than seeing a crab there and then the
other thing that we know exists if we
just fast forward to the end of cars
when we get to Wall-E is uh Hal the
Cockroach so like the cockroaches have
existed as well or have survived the
pollution which isn't really that
surprising that's sort of like
cockroach's whole deal well I think my
brain is still broken so let's move on
to Luca and monster Zing this is all
making perfect sense to you you don't
think about this every night I feel you
I feel you on little obsessions where
it's like no one else cares but I care
no I feel it and I care by the way I
can't this is why we're making this
video because I care too gosh darn it
but we got to move past cars because I
don't think we'll ever no one will ever
come to a consensus on that so let's
move on yeah Elio is coming out in 2025
it's a very sci-fi movie lots of
Technology I'm really hoping like yes
maybe cars happens in a different spot
now we'll have a better explanation but
we'll just see oh fascinating oh I can't
wait to see but for now let's go on to
Luca and Monsters Inc now there are two
big points regarding the sea monsters in
Luca and the monsters in Monsters Ink
that have been bothering me because they
don't seem to fit together one point you
make is that the sea monsters and the
humans begin to procreate creating the
monsters in Monsters Inc and then the
humans die out at some point which means
that the sea monsters are
so appealing that the humans are so
against procreating with other humans
that they'd rather let the population
die out than go on a second date with
another human what are these sea
monsters pickup lines oh man lot to
unpack there I care I care I understand
I understand so the idea is that when
the humans leave Earth on like the
axioms or the the star cruisers for the
sake of wall like the sea monsters are
able to still like stay on Earth and
just find Sanctuary Beneath the Sea in
the ocean so they stay on Earth the
humans come back 700 years later on the
one axium which is a really really big
ship so there's a lot of people on there
but that ship makes up the entire
population of humans on the planet at
that time so it's not really a ton
meanwhile the sea monsters have been
there so um if the upper world is now
habitable for humans again it means they
are now able to emerge from the oceans
again and once they're above the water
they just look like people which we see
uh in Luca so I think what's happening
is it's not a matter of that humans are
like determined not to date humans or
anything like that it's just that one uh
the genetic diversity on the Axiom not
super great since like those people's
parents and their parents and their
parents have all lived on the same ship
and that that's all they got so there's
all these new people now they can
intermingle with and they might not even
know that they're sea monsters you know
they just look like people and they're
just different people so I don't even
think it's a matter of like trying to um
not procreate with humans it's just a
matter matter of these are other people
and there's just more of them and so
they just sort of naturally take over
and the resulting Offspring starts to
become the monsters okay they've just
got this extra slime a little Sheen that
just makes them so feeling more
importantly than that though it's it's
the second point you make that seems to
throw a wrench at things for me cuz you
also say that the origins of the sea
monsters are that they're banished
monsters from Monsters Ink and they're
banished back in a time where Lucas
takes place but that seems to create a
paradox since if the monsters evolved
from the sea monsters the origins of the
sea monsters can be the monsters you
know because there would have already
been sea monsters to evolve into
monsters in order to banish sea monsters
right so it's like a little bit of like
a boot drop Paradox seemingly situation
going on there for sure where yeah the
answer to this Merida has a really great
line in Brave about Destiny and fate and
about how everyone has their own and
it's all sort of woven together into
like a big cloth or tapestry or it fits
really well you know inside specifically
brave but the overall point for the
greater movie is that if it ever
happened like it always happened so it's
like prisoner of aaban where it's like
it's not really an issue that when Harry
comes back to cast the Patronus to save
himself from serus that we haven't seen
Harry go into the future and come back
in time yet because like he always will
have done that he will always exist like
you don't necessarily need to know the
origin point it's all happening every
time every time so and that's basically
what's happening in the Pixar Universe
because in the future they do send the
sea monsters back they always send the
sea monsters back to go create the
monsters okay I I don't know if it
solves the Paradox but I but I
appreciate the explanation nonetheless
well now you mentioned Brave and let's
actually talk about Brave and The Witch
and and boo because this is the last big
concept where I just have so many
questions roughly the theory states that
the witch in Brave is buo who is on the
quest to keep Sol memory alive by
traveling back in time to ensure that
those events are set in motion which
will therefore ensure that Buu as a
little girl will always meet so and
therefore suly will always be remembered
you kind of sum this up with the
tapestry and everything is that about
right uh yeah that that's that's
basically it so it's like in the movie
Coco you see that like after people die
they sort of have this like second
existence in the afterlife and as long
as like anyone in the real world has
like a like a little memory orb of you
like from like inside out then you will
continue to exist inside of like that
afterlife world but once that final
memory orb of you is gone like you will
experience the uh the second death so Vu
is trying to avoid Sully ever
experiencing the second death another
part of this theory that I really enjoy
is uh that the Monsters Inc magic doors
can only go back so far I think that's
really clever but that the the time
moves parallel to the monsters time yes
that being said though at the end of
Monster Ink boo door is put back
together so if the years would progress
in monstropolis at the same rate as
Boo's time period why wouldn't suie be
able to continue to visit her and why is
the witch's door able to go back to any
time period when the monsters door
couldn't great questions I think to
answer your first question about like
why couldn't Sy visit her like more
often than just that one time I think he
totally could have and maybe he does we
it's just like we don't really know
maybe he maybe he continues to visit her
you know as she grows up but ites it
doesn't seem like that it feels like
it's implied that he just sort of goes
through that like one more time whatever
ration now he has for visiting as often
as he wants or just that one time is
just down to Sully so I he could have
visited her more if he wanted to we just
don't know whether or not he does do
that it's just that that's down to your
own personal interpretation or until we
get more data from the movies as for why
Boo's door is more effective at
traveling through time than the monsters
which can only travel back a set period
of time that is because Buu is like a
fully trained like magical person who
can like manipulate the magic whereas
the monsters are having to just just
like invent the magic with um technology
so theirs isn't as refined as hers is
okay so a Magic versus science kind of
kind of thing got it all right well Do's
aside let's assume for whatever reason
you'll have to ask su's therapist or the
cars therapist Buu can't see suly
anymore eventually but if the event of
her meeting suly already happened she
shouldn't have to like go back in time
and ensure it happens again right
because even if we assume that going
back and quote unquote reintroducing her
younger self to solely makes a
difference Boo at her current old age
will eventually die no matter how much
she time travels so wouldn't it be more
effective to teach a new little kid
about suly rather than time traveling
back to the same time period until she
eventually
passes uh you bring up some excellent
points and it's it really might have
been great if Buu knew you that might
that may indeed have been a more
effective plan it is not for me to
comment on why she determines that is
the correct course of action uh that's
that's up to her all I can do is connect
the dots based on what she did decide to
do even if there were clearly better
options at her disposal wow you really
said sucks to suck huh yeah you really
said it how that girl have magic where'
she learn that magic from yeah it's a
great question as well um this this
one's pretty easy though that we
actually get like a very um
straightforward answer in the movie
onward where you can see like on their
Planet the they there used to be some
people that just had magic and then you
know um they started developing
technology and they sorted get away from
it but the reason Buu has magic is just
because she's just it's just genetic
Lottery she just is born with magic it's
like Ian Can Do Magic but barley cannot
because he just he just can't oh man
that's a that's a heck of a lottery to
either win or lose it really is yeah but
you know I think I lost that Lottery but
hey what can you do I know I'm still
waiting on my letter to H warts myself
but well I'll tell you what I I really
am impressed at what an amazing job
y'all did with this for the audience if
you're like one if you have any other
questions like hey how did the toys and
Toy Story come to life or if you have
any lingering questions you have to
check out their original Pixar Theory
video or the 2022 one they answer
everything in there how the toys come to
life cars you know it's everything
everything be sure to go watch that and
I'll tell you what I am highly
anticipating seeing the next version of
this timeline you put together and
seeing it I you know maybe maybe
anything changes now you mentioned this
uh Pixar movie coming out in 2025 we
know that inside out 2 is coming out Toy
Story 5 eventually do you have any ideas
how uh the one that you mentioned is
going to fit into the timeline swirling
around maybe how ELO in 2025 it would be
great it would be so validating if
somewhere so what happens is like Elio
is this little boy and he gets abducted
on this like alien spaceship and they
think he's like the leader of Earth and
he gets to like interact with with this
like um the communiverse I think is what
they call it and it would it would be so
great so so great if somewhere in the
communiverse there was any character
from onward that like they had also piic
up from another planet and that like
just just doesn't have to have a part
just in the background that's what I'm
hoping for is that there's any notd to
onward in the communiverse that's what I
really want that would be like yes we
got it oh I'll cross my fingers for you
I want Lightning McQueen on that ship is
what that's right yeah that's right I
want to see a moving car on that ship
that comes down it's like oh that's how
cars got there well Jay thank you so so
much for joining me today I really
appreciate the great conversation and
you being so willing to have it uh it's
always good to to nerd out with a fellow
Pixar fan absolutely happy to do it
anytime if you have any other questions
about the Pixar theory just let me know
I'm sure I can think of something I'll
hit you up we got to wait for Helia
thank you so much and thank you so much
to everyone for watching and I want to
remind everyone that we're all good
vibes here and this Pixar theory is just
a fun challenge so I hope you'll show
the super Carin Brothers some love and
check out their Channel as well in the
meantime you can follow me on Twitter at
goom and follow And subscribe to new
rockstars at new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love later
[Music]
y'all